pour son premier déplacement non liés à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 depuis plus de
deux mois le président de la république
a choisi le département de l'aisne une
visite prévue de longue date puisqu'elle
marque que la première étape d'une année
d'hommages rendus au général de gaulle
emmanuel macron a prononcé un discours
pour commémorer la bataille de france et
plus particulièrement les combats de
montcornet qui se sont déroulés en mai
1940 un discours à la teneur très
historique mais dont certains passages
peuvent être lus à la lumière des
récents événements de gaulle nous dit
que la france est forte quand elle c'est
son destin quand elle se tient unis
qu'elles cherchent la voie de la
cohésion au nom d'une certaine idée de
la france qui nous rassemblent par delà
les discordes alors devenue accessoire
et les désaccords souvent trop vite yves
une ode à l'unité nationale un appel au
dépassement des clivages qui s'inscrit
dans la lignée de la volonté du
président de la république
l'hypothèse d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale apparaît d'ailleurs dans la
presse depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines
la tentation est grande donc de se
mettre dans les pas du général de gaulle
personnalité qui fait aujourd'hui
quasiment l'unanimité
cependant cet héritage se heurte aux
nombreuses réserves des oppositions
politiques de droite comme de gauche
pour certains emmanuel macron mêmes
l'antithèse du général de gaulle macron
au nord de gaulle macron qui en même
temps voulait réhabiliter pétain qui
détruit l'héritage social du conseil
national de la résistance qui brade la
souveraineté et l'indépendance de la
france
il est le contraire de de gaulle le
destructeur de son oeuvre
mascarade emmanuel macron et la
politique qu'il mène son psy contraire à
l'esprit et à la lettre du gaullisme que
l'hommage à charles de gaulle depuis
montcornet raisonnée las comme une
énième insulte à la nation
des arguments déjà exprimé il ya près de
deux ans lorsque l'évolution du logo de
l'ailé
avait été remarqué une croix de lorraine
il faisant son apparition il y avait eu
aussi les mémoires de charles de gaulle
ouvrage savamment disposés sur le bureau
de l'elysée pour la photo officielle du
président la tentative de captation du
gaullisme par emmanuel macron véritable
artifices de com comment peut-on se
prétendre gaulliste lorsqu'on veut une
europe fédérale qu'on nie l'existence
d'une culture française et qu'on accepte
de vendre deux aéroports à des
puissances étrangères
difficile à assumer sur le fond la
comparaison avec de gaulle il est aussi
sur la forme celui qui a incarné la
france libre et de loin le président le
plus populaire d'une vème république
rédigé sur mesure pour lui emmanuel
macron à l'instar de certains de ses
prédécesseurs tente donc un parallèle
père yves n'importe quel responsable
politique qui voudrait faire croire aux
français qu'il va marcher dans les pas
de de gaulle donnerait l'impression d'un
enfant qui a chaussé les bottes de son
papa vous voyez il ya une impression un
peu ridicule à la limite ce qu'il faut
faire c'est aller piocher à l'élire au
général de gaulle sans dire et s'en
inspirer pour que transparaissent à
travers notre action l'esprit de ce que
le général de gaulle a voulu insuffler
en matière de grandeur de la france
on attire deux puissances extérieures
emmanuel macron fait la baisse le
quotidien le monde nous apprend par
exemple que le président de la
république se serait replongé dans
l'histoire du général pour y puiser une
inspiration sûr je cite
comment un homme d'étape se servir
d'événements dramatiques pour redresser
la nation
mais face à tant de vent contraire il
n'est pas certain que même les mémoires
du général de gaulle suffisent à
emmanuel macron toujours contesté par
une grande partie des français